hi there guys I'm Lucy here with another
gamespot news update for you sweet
nutritious gaming news has been seeping
out of this year's san diego comic-con
and finally Bioware have given up some
goods on what we can expect from the new
Mass Effect game while their panel
mostly reiterated what the developer
said in their fancy behind-the-scenes
video from e3 back in June they did
reveal that the game will see the return
of the Mako vehicle from Mass Effect 1
yes everybody's favorite janky hard to
steer armored vehicle that could survive
a drop from space but not a hit from a
thresher maw is back I like the look of
it make 0 ver now it's more like a
souped-up quad bike with a roof than a
metal box on wheels and it's apparently
much faster than it used to be Bioware
said that the new mass effect will have
an emphasis on exploration and that the
maker will allow you to travel faster on
alien planets vaio I said that since
you'll spend a significant amount of
time in the vehicle they're also
considering allowing players to
customize how it looks finally I can
hang up those fluffy dice and head light
eyelashes that i bought on the citadel
repeating their e3 statements via where
said that the next Mass Effect will
feature a human protagonist who is not
commander shepard and there go my hopes
for a blast oh the hunter spectre
spinoff well maybe it's because he's a
big stupid jellyfish by well also didn't
say when or where the story will take
place in the Mass Effect universe and
while there's also no clues as to
whether we'll see any returning
characters will definitely see some
alien races that we all know and love
not love like that your minds out the
gutter well actually it's a matter of
fact so you might not be far off sadly
though that's where the Mass Effect news
ooze dries up publisher EA eclipsing
storm on which platforms the game will
release on or when we'll even see it
mentioning that it is still years away
so does the return of the Mako fill you
with dread or are you looking forward to
scaling those alien planets once more
and how are you gonna space pimp your
space right let us know in the comments
for the latest gaming news
they glued here to gamespot
you